- I loved you in "3rd Rock,"
so, is it true that your Mom once,
this is first of all,
I love your Mom and want to meet her
just from this story.
(chuckles)
- I heard she released bugs
in your co-star (chuckles)
John Lithgow's dressing room.
Like, first of all, bold,
- [Joseph] Yes.
(audience chuckling)
like super bold,
just like showin' out.
- This is context, but you're right.
My Mom is bold. That's true.
- I was like, wow.
- My Mom is a badass.
- What kind of bugs?
- Okay, so this started on April Fool's.
John Lithgow played a prank on everybody
and he told everybody royalty is coming,
Prince, I don't remember which prince,
I don't really keep track of the Royals.
- I don't either.
And like he sent out a whole memo,
and like made it look very official,
and you have to dress nicely.
- [Kelly] (laughs)
And like, my Mom got
me dressed up in a suit
because she got the memo
that Prince is coming or whatever.
Turned out it was an
April Fool's prank, right?
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
So, and she-
- That's elaborate.
She was the only one
that like got fooled.
- Oh.
So she decided, okay, I'm
gonna get this guy back.
And at the time I had a pet lizard,
like a pet,
and it was called, you
know, a bearded dragon.
You have you ever seen those lizards?
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah!
- We would feed her live crickets.
So we would go to the pet store every week
and bring home a bag of live crickets
to feed to my lizard.
- Please tell me she released crickets.
- So she went to the pet store,
got a bag of live crickets,
(audience laughs)
got someone to let her
into (chuckling) John
Lithgow's dressing room
and just let all the live crickets
out in his room. (chuckles)
(audience claps and laughs)
- I love
your Mom.
And you know that someone let her in
because that's someone
was also probably folding
their formal attire.
- Yeah, right, exactly.
She's wheelin' and dealin'.
- We're going to get this guy, yeah.
That's amazing, your Mom is awesome.
- My Mom is awesome, Kelly.
- That is so cool.
- Can I just say that again on television?
- My Mom, I'm so in love with her.
- She's so cool
(audience cheers)
and so funny.